extrem vermisst haben einfach Welle mit
ihrer sie schon mega mega traurig also
wenn ich zum Teil Technik sehen
ist Familie Generation alltäglich aber
wir bringt man Familie und Beruf um 3:00
Uhr das ist ein frage ich mir je länger
ihr müsst Stelle
Schlüssel her Mama
und Realität ist einfach
sieht alles geschafft hat aber ich bin
einfach immer krank den Brief nach dem
zweiten Video Stick gezahlt haben das
war der Preis vom abstiller und an dem
ich immer noch
[Musik]
ich werde mega gerne mal Mami sie aber
ich liebe auch meine Job und würde sehr
gern den winterschaffen als Journalisten
aufgewachsen bin ich ganz anders meine
Eltern
schaffe und inzwischen ist das ja auch
anders geht ganz viel Berufstätige und
viel wo sich dafür
ibarkeit von Job und Mami sie klappert
aber ich frage mich wie er machbar ist
es wirklich und was ist für mich der
richtige Weg und das Umsatz findet
[Musik]
genau
mit dem Auto unterwegs ab und zu bringt
auch endlich
Michaela schaffen 60 Prozent der Dave
Firma 80 ich nehme das im Umfeld oft
ähnlich Wort Männer schaffen
hochprozentiger als Frauen das ist
natürlich oft ein finanzielle Frage und
ob der Arbeitgeber wir wieder Michaela
mitmacht 6 Monate
mega cool verstanden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Bundesamt für Statistik sind im Jahr
2021 82% vor allem
die meisten schaffen nach der Geburt
vorstellen Prozent so oft
und ich aus 60% schaffen aber was war
wenn ich jetzt für 100% wählen schaffen
insgesamt 100% als älterer büroterin und
das ambulant die Woche Bett Betreuerin
[Musik]
alles vorbereitet
irgendwie ist es für mich schon
schwierig vorstellbar gar nicht im
Alltag von Michael ich weiß nicht klar
die beiden anderen sind noch wach
das rutscht schon wieder ab Alter
du Langschläfer
nur länger
kommt dass ich dann einfach Kinder
weniger gesehen aber ich hätte mir nicht
vorgestellt dass ich so
mega mega traurig also
Technik sehen
vor allem in jüngster
[Gelächter]
ja nicht mit vom Alltag
ehrlich telefoniere viel schrieben
trotz allem
[Musik]
das ist so die Idee schöne Seite von dem
Modell dass man die Kehrseite
drüben wir nicht unbezahlt hat und es
finanziell überbrücken
christina hat wird den intensiver darker
statt abschalten will sie die Zeit wo
bleibt aber mit einer Jungs verbringen
da
kleine
[Musik]
beim dritten so wichtig
dass du nicht abstellen
Auto Michaela Stelle sehr wichtig wenn
sie im Büro ist und 2 bis 3 mal am Tag
abpumpen
und koordiniere das Knoten
[Musik]
das mit dem abpumpe ist aber gar nicht
mal so einfach und klappt auch nicht
immer so wie man es gerade wird
[Musik]
okay
schwieriger
[Musik]
zur Verfügung stellen
als Berufstätigen
und das schmecker schön und ich grüße
beides
mit realisieren
[Musik]
oder zum Beispiel wegen mir spezielle
Bedürfnis und ich bin einfach los
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Reportage
vom Annabelle Magazin teilt und zwar
geht es in dem Post rum dass
Chefredakteurin Jacqueline
ich wollte mir beweisen dass es geht
Kinder und Karriere und bin an meinem
eigenen Ideal der working Superman
gescheitert
ich mache mich auf den Weg zum
Jacqueline
ihrem letzte Editorial hat sich
geschrieben dass immer irgendetwas auf
der Strecke bleibt
und ihre Tochter in
rapperswilerei
extrem vermisst haben einfach Welle mit
ihrer sie nicht mal dass ich
Schuldgefühl kann muss
[Musik]
tschüss auf jedes Editorial hat
Jacqueline sehr viel Rückmeldungen
endlich
mal eine ehrliche offenbar
perfekt die
Arbeit Erwerbstätige Mutter
die Fassade zu sprechen gefunden
als Frau
war mir so halt
fellinterpretiert hat hätte manch einer
sagen ja sie rief quasi Frauen dazu auf
einfach
erwerbstätigt sich muss immer
erwerbstätig sagen nicht schaffen und
das Handarbeit einige Fälle
interpretiert und um das ist mir
natürlich
[Musik]
mit viel reisen und mit viel Events und
ja sehr viele Repräsentation verbunden
extra schwer
was machst du da
das hat den ganz ganz
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der neue Feminismus ist für mich so
Ehrlichkeit und Frauen also Frauen sind
ehrlich zu Frauen damit man dann weiter
nur dann haben wir irgendwie überhaupt
den Dialog dass man nicht irgendwie so
komisch ideal muss wahre das Frau wo
erwerbstätig ist will sie sich das
selber aussucht muss das gefälligst auf
verdammt gut machen und sich nie
beschweren und das heuer irgendwie eine
Lösung
komplett am an weil sie immer so das
perfekt bildmin darstellen wann ich
anständige
älteren
teilt mit meinem Partner dann wäre ich
ganz anders also dann hätte ich
wahrscheinlich länger durchhalten
ich habe das jetzt mega spannend
gefunden mich mit der Jacqueline zu
deiner Themen und es hat mich einmal
drin bestärkt gesehen es hat auch ein
Wandel kein Feminismus und es ist so
wichtig dass man aber offen auch Sachen
anspricht nicht so gut funktioniert und
gleichzeitig natürlich
und hoffe einfach dass ich dann für mich
finde wo für mich stimmt jetzt würde
mich mega wundern was Ihr dazu sagen
was ganz anderes Modell unbedingt die
Kommentar und der kann ich nächste Frage
und wenn er gar nicht mehr verrückten
abonniert doch unbedingt diese Kanal